y
[Música]
cuando los bebés alguna vez
me acuerdo de esos miembros de familia
[Música]
cuando me dio
curioso no
es una escuela
[Música]
de g
en el proyecto
y ya
mejor y ellos no
es curioso porque el día de hoy quería
hablar sobre el estrés
y en esta conferencia
cuando ya preocupados
[Música]
cómo
porque estoy armando completo tu vida
[Música]
ahora
y es la única forma
[Música]
y
y más tiempo en internet es mayor
[Música]
me gusta
ya estaba proyecto
[Música]
recuerden
y un apocalipsis y hay una frase que
dice
por qué
[Música]
un libro que te cuente de aragón
trabajo
[Música]
y cortarlas
hacia personas para los materiales
para cortar las piezas unas 20 personas
más para poder entregar las piezas
estructuras 10 personas los 40 personas
en 100 dólares y pasamos de enviar a 400
por dónde pasa en este tiempo decides
laboral
las personas muertas el único modo que
tienes para celebrar la pobreza
trabajando porque trabajar
[Música]
pero no
accidente ahora santiago todas las
unidades y semanas trabajando 20 horas
al día durante 40 años hasta que el
cuerpo simplemente no podía más
y hablamos de todo esto que es todo
volvamos más
la edad media de las personas
varios puestos tenían que trabajar por
un trabajo
[Música]
de este modo las personas empezaron a
trabajar para padres y además serían
cobrando en cuenta entonces
por las condiciones
una vida limpia trabajan básicamente
mismo
esto también esta actividad
y ha cambiado
y
para trabajar con él
personas tienen una familia
[Música]
cuando el económico
empieza el agua caliente
[Música]
esos lugares
pero también
[Música]
no
de estas personas más
[Música]
no
contra la mente
las personas que como
por qué
a nivel de vida
[Música]
de quien depende la actividad
porque nos esforzamos tanto en conseguir
en verde los mejores
en términos mejor persona tiene el mejor
trabajo entender el juego simplemente en
el siempre de lo mismo
muchas personas la felicidad que
prefieren
[Música]
o qué
pero lo que no es natural es que estemos
muriendo cada vez más jóvenes para cosas
espantosas
común
y mucho menos de tu grupo social se
explaya
esta sede de productividad está dejando
con hambre el tiempo
[Música]
no
los jóvenes no pueden comprar esta caja
la playa contaminada
[Música]
aire
con los mismos
no hace falta que todos para darnos
cuenta ya tenemos
[Música]
voy a decir
[Aplausos]
[Música]